well well i got to say they crossed the
line here check out the story from nbc
news they did international cat
federation bans russian felines from
competitions just like we surrender it
is time to give up federation we cannot
keep doing this
too much which hosts over 700 cat shows
a year said it cannot just witness these
atrocities and do nothing what look at
these cats no
it's like okay i can understand that i
can understand the sentiment i can't
witness the these atrocities and not do
anything but like that that's the thing
you chose to do that wasn't your only
option you like did the russian so so
what if like what if an american is a
russian cat is that the issue or is it
like or is it like take him into the
street
out of here and some people talk three
year old sorry oliver some for a 60 year
old librarian has been waiting to show
her russian blue all year and it's like
she's from you know idaho and now she's
like what what do you mean i can't go to
the cat show it's like you're a
communist oh wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait it's not even that
wait look at that look at that cats
bread in russia no cat br so you could
be an american oh okay all right
they think they're genetically
imported or registered in any way but
what if that cat is a citizen in another
country
why is where they came from so important
to these people those cats are just
seeking a better outcome a better life
for themselves they're refugees
have they been bugged is that the
problem
back into citizenship for this i love
this timeline they're just
last through may 31st and will be
reviewed as and when
necessary like is any of this necessary
yeah yeah i don't understand why
democracy so like it's
this is this is war hysteria this is the
same thing as the mass formation
psychosis we heard about during covet
this is people being like
russia i need to put a ukrainian flag in
my twitter account and ban the cats oh
my goodness there's there's another
sentence here i really have to read um
on top of that our ukrainian fellow
feline fanciers are desperately trying
to take care of their cats and other
animals in these trying circumstances
there are far greater concerns there
far greater than saying like and we're
going to retaliate by banning russian
cats
the announcement is the latest blow to
russia
which has been hit with sanctions by a
number of countries they're reeling what
if you own a cat dude
is sitting in his chair stroking his cat
and he's like that's right he was like
no
yes
he cannot compete he like he looks at
his shelf and he's got all of his awards
from the cat show
a lot of alliteration did you find out
if you have a russian cap
if it was yeah it was bread in russia
they're going to come take it no no wait
bread and russia are born in russia
bread or
bread or important things because of or
not could have been bred there but then
could have given birth in another
country wait what yeah if if the cat are
you suggested
yeah it's an anchor are you just
yeah
we've gone for in 20 minutes we've gone
from the nuclear fire fight to anchor
kitties yeah the most important news
comes second there's like i think 11 11
this is tough cause this will be ripping
families apart if it goes through well
are you going to separate there's a
great restaurant in dc that is a russian
restaurant i'm almost reluctant to say
the name because i don't want to give
them names well they smashed the window
but there's smashed the windows yeah and
a friend of mine a friend of mine ate
there last night and said i've been
coming to this restaurant for like the
20 years i've lived in dc and it is a
russian restaurant but they're americans
they just have russian heritage and they
make russian food and now there's like a
boycott the restaurant and they must be
like you put me through friggin covet
and now you're putting me through this
like i just make borscht yeah how am i
responsible for this when well my
response was when i saw fifa had banned
russian clubs and teams or whatever from
the game i was just like
it's the stupidest thing ever and i said
you know what the russian people are to
blame to all of this they should be
punished i think that what we're getting
them from well hold on the funny thing
is when i tweeted i despise appeals to
emotion right yes the left went no you
were trending i found
referring to the translators more than
one there were three different
translators who cried while translating
and that was the viral story of course i
tweeted that because i tweeted about it
a bunch of different times and i made
videos about it but that doesn't play
well when they want to like criticize
like it's the weirdest thing ever
because i've been very like pro zelinski
and like been supportive of ukraine the
entire time so i don't know what they're
trying to smear but when they go when
they go nuts on this and then i tweet we
jokingly because they're all basically
like me just screwing around when i say
we must punish russian americans or my
favorite tweet was i said whoa how do we
know that russian americans aren't
secretly working for putin or worse
trump
no that did not make any of them angry
or when i said punish russian civilians
like that that didn't make anybody angry
but
how dare you question appeal to them the
the the sobbing translators
okay well y'all just banned cats so
what gets me about removing the russians
teams from the video game sports is like
uh okay i understand trying like world
war ii we put the japanese citizens
internment camps hardcore i don't know
if it was the right or wrong move maybe
they were spies maybe do the right thing
but like i used to play civilization and
hitler's never been any ever let any of
the german countries if you're playing
civilization you play germany hitler has
never been in the game they've
eradicated the the memory of that man
from the video game still 80 years later
they're still eradicating the memory so
like yeah the russian teams are gone
from sports this year what if in 80
years there's still like pretending
russia never existed
it's it's
effing terrifying so here's what here's
what gets me on all of these you know
and it's it's de-platforming do you
platforming cancel we're trying to use
cancel culture right
the same way that you know to affect
russia but
i i don't think they kind of unders like
this this was a planned operation this
wasn't like putin woke up one day and
said oh we're just going to do this did
you see the report that apparently xi
jinping said don't invade until after
the olympics are over maybe agreement
maybe maybe
i'm skeptical but at the same time you
know i think this is something that was
planned out for months in advance i
guarantee you that putin went around to
all of like the top oligar anyone who
has any actual sway within russia and
explained this is what's going to happen
next year so you need to set up your
stuff however you want to set it up and
and daniel you know this these guys have
stuff off the books in every country
around the world it's not in their names
not in their kids names yeah you can
take their yachts because you know it's
them but they've got mansions you don't
know about they've got planes you don't
know about and they're going to use them
and they're going to be fine so these
sanctions aren't going to hurt anyone
important in russia you're going to hurt
the regular people you're going to hurt
the disabled athletes that want to go to
the paralympics you're going to go after
the oncology researchers that are trying
to help people with cancer in uh in
russia right you're gonna hurt all of
those regular people behind the scenes
that's number one and number two is
you're gonna turn all of them not
against putin they're gonna be against
you because you put the sanctions on
what would you if you had been the
president when this happened last week
what would have been an adequate
response
well i mean
cancer you have to you have to go back
and say you know
we
we responded to escalation with more
escalation right
so it's we've been ratcheting up things
as they've been ratcheting up things and
so from the start you should have not
been doing that that's always the wrong
the wrong move obviously i i think uh
you know we needed biden to have because
we knew the invasion was coming biden
should have had a conversation with
putin a long time ago and he did and he
should have said if you hit ukraine i
will hit mask i'm sorry joe biden he
should have been like come on man
another joke
about those iranians donald trump
reportedly told putin if you try to take
ukraine i will hit moscow he said all
those beautiful golden turrets will be
destroyed yep do you remember my
favorite though he told she the same
thing if you go to taiwan i'll hit
beijing yeah and the story was that both
she and putin were like like kind of
shocked that someone would tell them i
will kill millions of civilians
if you take a ri if you engage in
regional conflicts remember trump timed
the original syria strikes for when xi
jinping was meeting at mar-a-lago over
dinner and there's you know there's a
story that as cake was being served they
leaned in and told xi jinping that the
strikes were taking place that's right
yeah but you remember when when putin
just met with when biden just met with
putin a couple months ago he came back
and he said we talked about seven things
that i told him were off limits i mean
right then and there i was like well
what if i'm number eight you know like
so seven things that you can't hit
seven american assets right we went
through seven things that he can't touch
that was after the cyber attack that
closed colonial pipeline so right off
the bat putin i mean if anything he
watched the state of the union he felt
more bold than me he's gonna say well i
didn't hit any of those seven things so
i'm good to go if you watch that if you
watch the super bowl halftime show he's
like they don't deserve to live anymore
like we should just invade the west
completely i think people need to
recognize that vladimir putin is
passionate
and he's old which means he's got to
make whatever move he's going to make
now because he's almost 70 years old so
i think i think russia is going to win
what they want to win i don't i we we
already have these crazy stories about
nato's involved they're 100 involved
they're just playing weird semantic
games latvia has apparently voted to
allow their citizens to join the fight
on the ukrainian side now how is that
not declaring war it's so ridiculous
well our military isn't involved we're
just sending waves of our own citizens
with guns into ukraine to shoot you that
to me is absurd plus you've got the
arming you've got the the uh
resources we'll put it that way being
given to ukraine so
it's ridiculous that we're at this point
where it's like well if nato gets
involved they're involved
yep so this is we're back under this is
something that i've noticed you know
kind of
zipping around on twitter reading a lot
of stuff
that we seem to have kind of forgotten
the sort of rules of the cold war like
the reason that we don't go directly
um
bullet to bullet we don't fire upon
russian assets and russian assets don't
fire on us so we have these proxy wars
right to we had afghanistan throughout
the 70s and 8 late 70s early 80s then we
had the vietnam war prior to that where
again russia of course was supporting
the viet cong and supporting the nva
and then we got involved in the south
but russia didn't actually send you know
they may have had a couple advisers but
they didn't send forces down um same
deal with korea right during the korean
war
russia didn't get directly involved they
had some air assets but they sent china
in they had north korea but they didn't
go in themselves same idea for us we
don't want to get into this shooting war
with another nuclear power so we end up
doing all these proxy wars and
essentially if you're looking at it from
russia's perspective they view the
current regime of the government of
ukraine and the ukrainian military as an
american or at least western proxy force
this is since uh 2014 since 2014
basically what the cia since the coup
instigated is is it like official that
the cio was involved or just assumed i
mean they were certainly involved and
they were certainly western yeah there
were certainly western assets involved i
mean you can you can have a debate about
you know who started it or who you know
whether or not it was justified but it
certainly was u.s supported and that
blockaded and like hindered their
ability to get oil into the black sea so
that's why he took crimea almost
instantly after that
well it i mean it changed a lot of
things obviously but they were looking
at a situation where
remember the russian black sea fleet
it's at that port of ostafa has always
been there right that's always been a
russian naval port and that's their
major port uh their major navy base on
the black sea so they were never going
to give that up they just they just
weren't going to it's their only warm
water port it also grants them access to
the mediterranean
yeah which causes issues with uh the
bosphorus in turkey because turkey
controls
it's it's russia's already in a a
weakened position with that being yeah
with turkey being in nato i mean how do
they get through the boss first well so
i mean that's why they're taking ukraine
so they go over land if if you need to
get through the bosphorus you know just
because turkey says no it doesn't mean
you can't get through yeah i think there
was a big issue with that because russia
did it no i think the u.s did
somebody was like we don't care just
went and turkey was like yeah yeah
shipping routes man i think the suez is
also underrated i think a big part of
why the military built up in the middle
east that the united states has been
doing is to protect the suez canal and
shipping 100 but also look at
if you want to go through and actually
look at what we can see not the
apocalyptic you know version of greta
thunder climate change but the actual
climate change effects that if you look
at that northern sea route that's
opening up across
essentially the arctic ocean russia is a
clear beneficiary of all of this because
you can make it from dalian china to
rottenburg
denmark in like two-thirds the time or
even half the time that you would take
that you would need to go through the
south china sea and then the suez canal
if you cut that all around that's the
reason that russia knows that going 15
years from now they're gonna be the ones
in charge of that northern sea route i
would advise anyone that's listening to
the show um to pull up like a map a
google map or like some sort of map and
follow along yeah because it's really
cool type in the names of these places
and you can understand geographically
what what's going on well thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and we'll
see you all there
you